[Musique]
bonsoir à tout ça nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter des grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 17 février les
tensions montent d'un cran dans la crise
ukrainienne des échanges de tirs
auraient eu lieu dans le donbass
washington redouble d'accusation contre
moscou affirmant que ses troupes n'ont
pas diminué mais au contraire augmenté à
la frontière ukrainienne joe biden
répète qu'une invasion est imminente la
russie elle annonce pourtant un nouveau
retrait militaire récuse à l'onu
l'ukraine de ne pas appliquer les
accords de minsk nous irons à washington
est de nier est ce vraiment un
décryptage sur cette situation complexe
avec nos invités
les troupes françaises barkan devrait
quitter le mali dans les six prochains
mois épilogue de la rupture
franco-malienne les militaires français
leurs alliés de taku bas devraient se
plier se replier en afrique de l'ouest
annonce ce matin d'emmanuel macron lors
d'une conférence de presse conjointe
avec ses homologues sénégalais et
ghanéens comment la population malienne
voit ce retrait quel bilan de
l'intervention française alors qu
emmanuel macron réfute un échec anna
glisse dans quelques minutes
et puis dans cette émission notre rendez
vous éco avec jacques sapir au menu
aujourd'hui comment réindustrialiser la
france pour réduire sa dépendance de
l'extérieur
la plupart des candidats à la
présidentielle d'eric zemmour à fabien
rochelle en passant par valérie pécresse
vont de leurs solutions aujourd'hui se
donne t'on vraiment les moyens de
réindustrialiser alors que notre pays
s'est vidée de ses usines au fil des
décennies éléments de réponse autour de
20h45
et puis on se met à 21h la chronique de
campagne et on est maintenant à moins de
deux mois du premier tour de la
présidentielle et à gauche comme à
droite les défections les coups bas où
les petites trahisons entre amis
rythment le quotidien des parties rien
ne va plus au sein du rassemblement
national marine le pen trahi par son
camp son porte parole de campagne
nicolas bay et même suspendu de ses
fonctions et a rejoint le parti d'eric
zemmour la candidate et l'air avec des
ris pécresse elle n'a pas la sympathie
de son mentor nicolas sarkozy qui ne
cessent de la critique et enfin de son
côté ségolène royal affirme que le vote
utile à gauche c'est mélenchon
décryptage en troisième partie de cette
émission
[Musique]
dans l'actualité donc les etats unis qui
mettent un nouveau coup de pression à la
russie pour le président joe biden le
risque d'une invasion de l'ukraine par
moscou est très élevé ce soir le chef de
la diplomatie américaine anthony blinken
a décrit devant l'onu le scénario d'une
attaque on en parle avec à notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnet
bonsoir thomas devant le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies anthony
blinken a donc exhorté la russie à
abandonner la voie de la guerre
oui anthony blinken qui avait donc
décidé de se rendre en personne à cette
réunion du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies une étape dans son voyage
qui devait le conduire à munich on nous
dit qu'il ya eu de longues consultations
entre la maison blanche et le
département d'état américain pour
finalement parvenir à la décision que ce
soit anthony blinken a qui prennent la
parole il a donc pris la parole il y à
quelques heures maintenant il explique
que nous sommes face à un moment de
péril pour des millions de personnes il
réaffirme que les états unis ne peuvent
toujours pas vérifié le retrait d'une
partie des troupes russes le long de la
frontière ukrainienne au contraire les
autorités américaines explique que la
russie a renforcé ses capacités
militaires dans la région au cours des
derniers jours il a même donc donné
quelques détails sur ce à quoi pourrait
ressembler une offensive de la russie en
ukraine et il répond également à ceux
qui mettraient en doute les affirmations
des autorités américaines écouter
attaque interviendrait dans un deuxième
temps des missiles des bombes serait
largué en ukraine les communications
serait brouillé des cyberattaques
réduire à néant les institutions
ukrainienne clé après cela des chars des
soldats russes avancerez visant des
cibles déjà identifié
cartographier de manière très détaillée
nous pensons que ces cibles sont
notamment la capitale de la de l'ukraine
kiev une ville de 2 8 millions de
personnes je sais que d'aucuns ont remis
en question les informations
communiquées par moi même rappelant que
par le passé des renseignements obtenus
s'était avéré erroné mais que les choses
soient claires je suis ici aujourd'hui
non pas pour lancer une guerre mais pour
en empêcher une
selon le chef de la diplomatie
américaine moscou doit désormais
démontrer sa volonté de désescalade en
renvoyant les troupes russes dans leurs
casernes alors il ya eu une réaction du
représentant russe lors de cette réunion
du conseil de sécurité à des nations
unies il regrette le fait que washington
fasse monter les tensions et que les
déclarations russes de ces derniers
jours ne soient pas entendus par les
pays occidentaux écoutez le
trouve cela dommage
qu'on n'ait pas entendu les affirmations
les déclarations très sérieuse de
monsieur poutine ces derniers jours sur
la situation en ukraine dans l'est de ce
pays alors je demanderai à nos
partenaires d'écouter ce qu'il a dit à
la conférence de presse
alors qu'à moscou
il y avait
le président de la france le chancelier
de l'allemagne
qui est à l'issue de ces pourparlers à
une conférence de presse et donc nos
invités et le président de la fédération
de russie se sont exprimés
parmi les autres prises de parole lors
de cette réunion du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies on a notamment pu
entendre le représentant britannique
formule est lui aussi ses inquiétudes
sur la situation le long de la frontière
ukrainienne ou encore le représentant
chinois qui estime que l'élargissement
de l'otan est une question que l'on ne
peut pas évacuer face aux tensions en
ukraine alors un peu plus tôt dans la
journée c'est le président américain à
joe biden qui s'étaient exprimés face à
des journalistes il affirme à nouveau
qu'une attaque de la russie pourrait
intervenir dans les tout prochains jours
écouté le
nous avons des raisons de croire qu'ils
sont engagés dans une opération prétexte
pour avoir une excuse pour y aller
toutes les indications que nous avons
c'est qu'ils sont prêts à rentrer en
ukraine attaque et l'ukraine
le président américain qui explique
aussi qu'il n'a pas prévu à ce stade de
s'entretenir par téléphone avec vladimir
poutine en tout cas au cours des
prochains jours en revanche anthony
blinken aurait proposé une réunion à son
homologue russe sergueï lavrov pour le
courant de la semaine prochaine enfin
washington prépare également sa réponse
suite à l'expulsion par moscou du numéro
deux de l'ambassade américaine en russie
un acte considéré par le département
d'état américain comme une étape
supplémentaire dans l' escalade
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington et la russie qui annonce de
son côté donc de nouveau retrait qui
contraste avec les accusations
occidentales
le kremlin évoque tout de même un
processus long mais entamé malgré tout
rien ne semble convaincre washington le
département d'état américain affirme
même que moscou a expulsé le numéro deux
de l'ambassade américaine en russie les
précisions de notre correspondante à
moscou maëlys d'estrées
les etats-unis ont annoncé l'expulsion
de leur ambassadeur adjoint en russie
quelques heures plus tôt l'ambassadeur
américain s'est rendu au ministère des
affaires étrangères russe puis est
reparti une quinzaine de minutes plus
tard entre temps la diplomatie russe a
publié un communiqué de 11 pages
contenant sa réponse aux propositions
américaines quant à la sécurité en
europe la russie reproche aux états unis
de déformer en leur faveur et celle de
leurs alliés les propositions qu'elle
leur a fait précédemment elle affirme en
outre que washington privilégie les
thèmes qui lui conviennent en matière de
garanties négligeant les propositions
clés sans lesquelles d'après moscou il
ne peut y avoir de sécurité en europe
les états unis n'ont pas confirmé dans
leurs réponses être pleinement attachée
au respect du principe immuable
d'indivisibilité de la sécurité les
déclarations d'ordre général sur la
prise en compte par la partie américaine
de ce postulat sont en contradiction
directe avec la réticence de washington
a renoncé à une politique contre
productive et déstabilisatrices visant à
créer des avantages pour eux mêmes et
leurs alliés au détriment des intérêts
de sécurité de la russie moscou répète
par ailleurs ne planifiait aucune
invasion de l'ukraine et réclament le
départ des forces américaines d'europe
centrale et orientale
l'activité militaire croissante des
états unis et de l'otan directement à
proximité des frontières russes est
alarmante alors que nos lignes rouges et
nos intérêts fondamentaux en matière de
sécurité ainsi que le droit souverain de
la russie de les protéger continue
d'être ignoré les exigences sous forme
d'ultimatum demandant le retrait des
troupes de certaines régions du
territoire russe accompagnée de menaces
de durcissement des sanctions sont
inacceptables et sape les perspectives
d'accord réel moscou 10 attentes de
washington et de l'otan des propositions
concrètes quand un élargissement de
l'alliance atlantique vers l'est la
russie a par ailleurs fait savoir que sa
réponse à l'otan en matière de garanties
de sécurité était en cours d'élaboration
et qu'elle ne serait donc pas envoyé ce
jeudi est sur le terrain dans l'est de
l'ukraine la situation sur la ligne de
contact se dégradent qui a fait les
rebelles s'accusent mutuellement de
bombardements et de violation des
accords de minsk on retrouve notre
envoyé spécial antoine claireaux ados
n'y est que bon soir antoine quels sont
les derniers développements dans le
donbass
bonsoir stéphanie et bien je peux vous
dire que toute la journée ici à donetsk
des échanges de tirs ont eu lieu entre
les forces du craignent haine et la
milice de la république autoproclamée de
donner à ce qu'au total les autorités
locales ont relevé pas moins de vingt et
une violation du cessez le feu pour un
total de 93 projectiles de différents
calibres qui ont été tirés depuis
l'ukraine vers le territoire de la
république populaire des déflagrations
que l'on pouvait donc entendre depuis le
centre-ville de donetsk moi-même dans la
matinée j'ai pu entendre des bruits
sourds et l'on atteint qui correspond
qui correspondait donc à ces explosions
et cela a fait des dégâts sur des
immeubles d'habitation et des maisons en
banlieue de dounia je vous propose
d'écouter les témoignages de résidents
écouter les robots
notre village a été bombardé il y a des
dégâts chez nous et chez notre voisine
aussi c'était du côté nord ou dans une
rue voisine quelque part à proximité
quand une bombe explose la portée est
approximativement de 50 à 70 m
j'aimerais vraiment que ce soit bientôt
fini pour qu'au moins quelques uns nous
protège je veux dire la fédération de
russie
à 9h30 environ le bombardement a
commencé c'était loin d'abord puis de
plus en plus proche vers 10h ou 10h30 on
a entendu un fracas cement ici tout près
des éclats me sont tombés dessus je me
suis précipitée chez moi pour me mettre
à l'abri
les échanges de tirs ont également
concerné la république voisine de
lougansk d'ordinaire un peu plus calme
que celle de deux nièces qu'en tout cas
dans les deux républiques autoproclamées
celle de donetsk est lougansk on rejette
la responsabilité de l'ouverture des
hostilités sur le cren et inversement je
vous propose d'écouter la réaction la
déclaration d'un responsable de la
république populaire de lougansk écouter
[Musique]
depuis deux jours la journée la
situation s'est brutalement aggravée sur
la ligne de contact les soldats ne
craignait ont déjà violé dix fois le
cessez le feu en bombardant cette
localité de la république des armes
interdites par les accords de minsk sont
abondamment utilisé afin de se disculper
d'actions criminelles la pâque juive
chrétienne lance de fausses informations
et publie des éléments préparé au
préalable qui montre des infrastructures
civiles détruites prétendument à la
suite des tirs effectués par la milice
populaire
le retrait annoncé par la russie de
certaines de ses troupes en crimée par
exemple pouvait inciter à penser que
l'on se dirigeait vers une désescalade
mais voilà on dirait bien il semble en
tout cas que les tensions se soit
déplacé au niveau de la ligne de
démarcation entre l'ukraine et les deux
républiques les deux républiques
autoproclamées du donbass merci antoine
claireaux alors pourquoi l'étang surnom
d'un cran dans ce dossier ukrainien
pourquoi les états unis restent sourds
aux affirmations de moscou sur le
retrait des troupes à la frontière quels
enjeux se cache derrière tout cela c'est
l'heure de notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau régis le sommier grand reporter
rt france bons soient régis merci d'être
avec nous et emmanuel leroy président de
l'institut 17-17 bonsoir emmanuel leroy
pour nous accompagner également jacques
myard mer et l'air de maisons laffitte
bonsoir jacques myard merci d'être là
donc depuis quelques bons soirs depuis
quelques jours scénario donc à
rebondissements invente hier régis
soumis ont parlé ensemble de détente un
ici même sur ce plateau est aujourd'hui
rebelote
joe biden qui annonce décidément une
invasion imminente annoncé pour hier on
attendait hier un sav 10 16 février avec
même des horaires à l'appui
joe biden qui croit savoir aussi que les
russes augmentent leurs troupes alors
que ces derniers disent le contraire on
a décidément du mal à suivre
on a du mal à suivre on voit qu'on est
toujours dans une espèce de surenchère
notamment de la part de la part de la
partie américaine
surenchère qui est à la fois de l'ordre
des politiques et pas que joe biden
s'est également partagé par les
démocrates et les républicains aux états
unis à quelques exceptions près bernie
sanders ou quelques ténors aussi de des
deux parties et qui exprime certaines
réserves si justement sur cette cet état
d'esprit un peu alarmiste même très
clairement alarmiste il ya aussi
toujours la presse internationale la
presse en tout cas américaine qui qui
pousse on a l'impression que cette
musique on la connaît qu'elle a été
c'est un scénario qu'on a déjà entendu
un jeu ceux qui ont à l'époque été aux
états unis en 2003 au moment de la
guerre en irak se souviennent de ses 17
espèces d'emphase tout à coup on peut se
permettre de dire à peu près tout et
n'importe quoi de l'adversaire il n'y a
plus aucune mesure et en même temps tout
ça on sent bien et encouragé par le
pouvoir là
là il ya quand même bon dd des signes
contradictoires on a dit c'est ces
escarmouches qui commença enfin en tout
cas ces échanges de tirs qui peuvent te
va comment exister dans la partie est de
l'ukraine qui sont quand même inquiétant
même si il faut quand même reconnaître
que cette cette guerre larvée existe
dans l'est de l'ukraine depuis 2000
jaliya il y a eu il ya eu quand même au
fil depuis 2014 plusieurs périodes de
tension et des périodes d'accalmie dans
ces zones là il ya toujours des
tranchées de part et d'autre on est
toujours dans une situation qui est
instable donc là oui en effet il ya des
échanges de tirs aujourd'hui caractérisé
la sueur sur les russes par le fait est
que les comment les manoeuvres
militaires ce qui s'est passé mercredi
qui était quand même assez décisif c'est
avec les manoeuvres militaires entre la
russie entre l'armée russe et l'armée
biélorusses ont pris fin donc du coup
une partie des trous en effet sont
revenus dans leurs casernements il a les
troupes étaient également mobilisés en
crimée donc il ya aussi une fin annoncée
est prévue de ces exercices donc là les
américains continuent à on comprend pas
très bien le problème en fait c'est
qu'on comprend pas très bien ce que
cherche comment joe biden à ce stade
parce que en étant tout en étant
président américain américain il ya des
raisons pour lesquelles c'est comment
cette crise existe mais quel était
l'intérêt pour lui de prévoir comme vous
l'avez dit mercredi matin à l'aube il y
aura une intervention
quel était l'intérêt de mettre en avant
la crédibilité
non mais mais mais c'est c'est toujours
que ce soit le sun en angleterre où
quelques journaux comme ça qui se décrit
bid ibiliz en donnant leur en 10 ans à 3
heures du matin attention il va y avoir
des attaques de chars certes mais joe
biden le président américain est comme
ce qu'en plus ça ne se produit pas on
finit par se poser des questions jacques
myard régis aux menées
venez nous parler d'une petite musique
évidemment avec entre guillemets cette
petite hystérie américaine et anglo
saxon notamment dans la presse alors
c'est pas un concerto de violon c'est la
grosse caisse comment vous expliquez
cela vous vous vous y croyez justement
cette invasion imminente
écoutez savez il peut toujours y avoir
des dérapages évier pauthe mais ce qui
est certain c'est que l'évangile selon
la cia il ya longtemps que je ne crois
plus que je ne crois plus c'est sans
doute un évangile je dirais apocryphe
donc il est évident que les états unis à
la tête de l'otan qui est une machine
américaine veulent reconstituer un
ennemi idéal ils ont eu des déboires
fort en afghanistan il me le montrer
parce que il n'ya savez au sein de
l'union européenne
beaucoup de divergences si vous prenez
la pologne si vous prenez les états
balle ils ont une crainte de l'ex urss
et de la russie de poutine aujourd'hui
il n'en demeure pas moins que la france
a toujours dit qu'il s'était et qu'elle
s'opposera à l'entrée de l'ukraine dans
l'otan c'est la clé c'est la clé et donc
s'inscrire aux enchères côté d'asus ne
tique parce que depuis des décennies
depuis 30 ans les russes disent
attention la preuve de l'otan près des
frontières va constituer vous dirait une
tension forte et tous est une faute et
on peut le comprendre
on peut parfaitement le comprendre je
suis de ceux en tant que gaulliste qui
pensent que la russie fait partie de
l'équilibré 1 mais de grâce cessons à
longueur de temps de faire d'elle ou
d'essayer de faire d'elle un ennemi dial
donc aujourd'hui je regrette d'ailleurs
que le président macron ne t'a pas un
peu du poing sur la tête sur la table
mais il est dans une contradiction parce
que il fait un euro lattre convaincu et
ne t'a pas du prince sur la table pour
des remarques à maintenant ça suffit
nous nous opposons à l'entrée
de l'ukraine dans le temps et je pense
que ça c'est la clé je dirais de la
baisse de tension ce qui ne veut pas
dire ensuite qu'il faut pas trouver des
solutions pour john bass et say say say
yeah d'escarmouches perpétuelle qui peut
créer des tensions et surtout qui peut
tuer les civils donc la clé c'est en
réalité le fait que l'ukraine ne doit
pas rentrer dans l'otan parce que ce
serait au regard de la russie une
provocation
difficile à admettre et c'est ça le
problème manifestement il ya vraiment
une lecture totalement différente parce
que il ya cette ligne rouge russe dont
vous nous parler cette extension de
l'otan et puis selon effectivement la
version américaine anglo saxon
occidentale même française il ya voilà
le cette envie corée la russie de
recréer l'union soviétique d'ailleurs
les échanges de tirs dans le donbass
avons parié du don bassin jacques myard
boris johnson qui accuse aujourd'hui la
russie provocation visant à discréditer
kiev je cite et à justifier une
intervention effective
on peut se demander l'intérêt qu'aurait
absolument la russie a à faire c'est un
jour il est clair il est clair que dans
cette affaire de l'ukraine ni l'ukraine
ni la russie n'ont intérêt à cette
guerre exemple ce serait des
gens n'en suis moins sûr que j'en suis
moins sûr que vous je crains c'est le
jeu que l'on auquel on assiste
d'ailleurs et qui se souvient en parler
à un instant toute la propagande de
guerre qui se fait aujourd'hui provient
des états unis et de londres et de
l'angleterre de la grande bretagne est
manifestement il ya une volonté de nuire
à l'intérêt pour les avez peut-être que
peut-être que la situation interne aux
états unis n'est pas si bonne que cela
et que une guerre constituera un
excellent dérivatif donc ça c'est une
hypothèse qui est en ligne de mire
l'autre hypothèse et c'est que et on
n'en parle pas souvent la moitié de
l'armée ukrainienne est concentré dans
le dos basse prête à partir à l'assaut
comme elle l'était déjà il ya un an en
avril 2000 2021 aux côtés de cette arme
et l'ukrainienne il y a des forces
spéciales américaines anglaises
canadienne polonaise qui sont sur le
terrain et ce sont ceux sur ses forces
spéciales là que compte l'otan pour
déclencher les provocations qui
entraînerait une réaction russe et c'est
pour cela que monsieur by dane monsieur
johnson et les journaux qui le reçoit un
feed et annonce que la guerre va
démarrer dans 18 heures 12 heures 14
c'est que ils attendent que leurs forces
spéciales agit sur le terrain mais j'ai
l'impression que les russes ne font
jouer une pression très forte pour que
cet assaut ne démarre pas je conduis
rajoutera et pardonnez moi je vais vous
rajoutez juste un mot oui pour revenir
sur ce que disait donc monsieur jacques
maire un instant bien sûr il est évident
que l'ukraine ne doit pas entrer dans
l'otan mais la véritable condition du
retour de la paix en ukraine c'est le
respect des accords de minsk il suffit
que monsieur zelensky déclarent les
pardonnez moi rêver lors des accords de
ministre
au menu de l'eau news aujourd'hui
justement mais je voudrais vous montrer
des images justement à kiev pendant que
les anglo saxons bondissent voilà l'idée
d'une invasion imminente
regardez ces centaines de manifestants
alors on se dit ils manifestent contre
la guerre contre et bien non tout
simplement contre la réforme des taxes
en une mesure de politique intérieure
donc on est on est vraiment très très
loin
[Musique]
oui j'allais vous demandez ce mais
comment on explique ce décalage entre
ces personnes ont regardé on se croirait
à paris les petites manifestations
là on n'est pas dans un pays qui va
va qui semble en tout cas les habitants
n'ont pas cette conscience
on est dans un pays qui traverse une
crise économique très grave dans lequel
effectivement il ya beaucoup de
contestations avec elle le gouvernement
des vingt ce qui n'est pas sûr
d'ailleurs d'être reconduit aux affaires
et que dans lequel beaucoup d'opposants
ont été arrêtés aussi enfin il faut
regarder la réalité ukrainienne comme
une économie qui est en berne depuis 30
ans en plus une économie qui n'arrive
pas à décoller donc évidemment cette
tension et cette crise ne vont pas
améliorer les choses pour l'économie
ukrainienne qui dans le même temps voix
des pays comme la pologne ou la roumanie
prospérer à ses frontières avoir des
taux de croissance importants et donc
voilà l'ukraine est à nouveau plombé par
cette se pare d un enjeu qui finalement
la dépasse puisque on sent bien que les
intérêts américains dans l'histoire
c'est pas simplement protéger l'ukraine
les américains opus agite le chiffon
rouge 2 de la sacro-sainte intégrité de
l'ukraine sur laquelle il faut
absolument comment intervenir si la
russie envahi et puis dans le même temps
10 nous n'en verrons nous n'en verrons
aucun soldat ils ont même retiré leur
186,3 de soldats l'ukraine en disant on
va les redéployer à côté on va envoyer
un contingent de 3000 soldats en pologne
tout simplement pour respecter les
accords de l'otan qui stipule que comme
en vain dans l'otan finalement il faut
mettre des amendes et des soldats
américains pour défendre comme il ya des
heston des français en estonie où il ya
des français en roumanie pour me pose
pour dire en défense si les russes
attaque ces pays là à la suite de
l'ukraine on peut imaginer ou dans le
même temps eh bien il se met en position
de tuer des français des anglais des
américains voilà donc la la c'est cela
c'est là le le rôle défensif de l'otan
mais l'ukraine ne fait absolument pas
partie de l'otan donc il n'y a pas de
raison donc d'un ce et c'est toujours le
même problème avec les américains ils
sont toujours très très fort pour
déclencher des guerres qui soit disant
comment détermine le l'avenir du monde
souvenez-vous avec saddam hussein
souvenez vous
également nous après avec kadhafi ou
tout à coup des gens qu'on a toléré
pendant 30 ou 40 ans et avec qui on
s'est très bien entendu deviennent les
nouveaux hitler parce que le la donne du
moment faut fait qu'il faut intervenir
mais pour les américains ça ne se passe
jamais sur leur territoire c'est
toujours très loin c'est toujours
quelque chose qui ne m'ont pas avoir à
subir nous on européen on nous devons
regarder l'ukraine comme faisant comme
un pays très proche de l'europe voire
faisant partie de l'europe et dans une
guerre en ukraine aura des conséquences
sur sur l'europe aura des conséquences
sur ce continent elle n'aura pas de
conséquences sur l'avenir des états unis
donc là c'est toujours la même chose et
donc oui pourquoi pourquoi continuer à
comment agité les choses je pense qu'il
ya un comment monsieur byden a commis
deux erreurs fondamentales donc ça a été
ça a été évoqué ce retrait calamiteux
d'afghanistan qui a été
co conduit à une dégradation de son
comment de son image au niveau de
l'opinion publique est également ce qui
s'est passé avec la subtilisation du
contrat comment australien lui en amont
il a montré qu' il traitait extrêmement
mal ses alliés peut-être là aussi il ya
de la part des américains une volonté de
resserrer les rangs autour d'eux et 2
justement face à une cause commune et du
coup l'ukraine devient le prétexte oui
sept non
bien évidemment
l'otan est une machine américaine
et donc elle s est la première
organisation politique en europe celle
de la défense de plus il y a un problème
majeur aux etats unis c'est qu'il
n'existe pas une seule politique
étrangère et le président pendant la
tête effectivement et en faisant ses
déclarations essaie de regrouper
l'ensemble des divers éléments qui font
la politique étrangère que ce soit le
pentagone que ça soit la cia ne
s'assoient le commerce on s'assoit bref
et donc ils essayent de remettre tout le
monde au garde à vous parce que il a
perdu l'aura du chef en afghanistan
c'est aussi ça que ça il faut le savoir
mais ce qui est certain c'est que
aujourd'hui une guerre en europe et on
le traîne seul me la faire et d'ailleurs
les ukrainiens sont beaucoup plus calme
semble le dire les américains mais il
est vraiment ces images c'était le sens
de voeux parce que quand on est au bord
de la guerre on va peut-être pas
manifester contre la réforme bintec
saint malo l'aîné des articles de la
presse française montrent qu' il ya un
certain calme bien sûr on va vous dire
il ya les aprilia et cetera j'ai entendu
quelques papiers sur des radios d'état
mais il n'en demeure pas moins que
aujourd'hui il ya une volonté américaine
de m les alliés européens au garde à
vous ce que je regrette c'est que le
président de la république française de
nice patent dès maintenant ça suffit
mais pourquoi il peut pas le dire parce
qu'il prétend être un euro je dirais
convaincu et donc il fait la quadrature
du cercle parce que les polonais peut
pas être d'accord avec ce qu'il peut
dire ou avec les allemands il ya aussi
cette histoire du gaz donc on voit très
bien en réalité l'union européenne c'est
le je dirais les forces centrifuges en
permanence tout la nécessité d'avoir une
politique nationale propre à la france
mais j'ai aimé l'oral le mot de la fin
pour vous on arrive déjà à la fin de ce
décryptage en justement ce qui s'est
passé à l'onu à la rue si vous voulez
parler des secteurs de minsk justement
accuse l'ukraine de ne pas respecter ces
accords de minx c'est là aussi une des
clés peut-être c'est la clé du confit ce
la clé de résolution du conflit si
demain monsieur tennis qui applique les
accords de minsk 2 tels qu'ils ont été
signés tels que l'ukraine des affiliés
et tels que la france et l'allemagne en
sont les garants aux côtés de la russie
la paix sera inévitablement de retour en
ukraine pour tout le monde et c'est
impérativement ce qu'il faut faire il ya
un point sur lequel j'aurai quand même
intervenir pour revenir sur ce qui était
dit au départ parce que c'est gravissime
les bombardements quotidiens qui dure
depuis huit ans sur les populations
civiles du dôme bas ce sont des crimes
de guerre se sont pas ceux sont pas des
opérations militaires ce sont des crimes
de guerre quand une armée vie libéra nom
des populations civiles ça s'appelle des
crimes de guerre qui sont justement
banni par les accords de minsk et c'est
eux qu'il faudrait respecter pour faire
revenir la paix dans ce pays merci
manuel leroy merci régis au sommier
merci également à vous jacques myard
et c'est donc au coude c'est donc
officiel l'opération barkan va quitter
le mali dans un délai de six mois et
mesdames les crocs en a fait l'annoncé
ce matin lors d'un point presse du côté
aux côtés notamment de ses homologues
sénégalais et ghanéens la france qui
prévoit 1 re déploiement de ses troupes
avec takouba en afrique de l'ouest katia
technique
c'était attendu la france ses
partenaires européens le canada ont mis
fin à leur engagement militaire au mali
neuf ans pour la france après
l'enchaînement des opérations serval
barkan et à kouba le retrait déjà
anticipé a été précipitée par les
rapports tendus entre la france et le
pouvoir de transition malien mise en
place par les militaires emmanuel macron
a évoqué les multiples obstruction des
autorités de transition malienne il a
affirmé que les conditions n'étaient
plus réunies pour poursuivre
efficacement l'engagement militaire
actuelle toutefois la france à ses
partenaires vrai seront investis dans la
lutte contre le djihadisme au sahel et
dans le golfe de guinée de 2500 à 3000
soldats français vont ainsi ré s'est
déployée au sahel après leur départ du
mali d'ici quatre à six mois la france
va continuer d'assurer les missions de
sécurisation de la minus ma la mission
de l'onu au mali au que deux des casques
bleus emmanuel macron a évoqué la
question en conférence de presse ce
matin à l'elysée on écoute
la lutte contre le terrorisme ne peut
pas tout justifier
elle ne doit pas sous prétexte d'être
une priorité absolue se transformer en
exercice de conservation indéfinie du
pouvoir elle ne peut pas non plus
justifier une escalade de la violence
par le recours à des mercenaires dont
les exactions sont documentés en
république centrafricaine et dont
l'exercice de la force mais encadrées
par aucune règle ni par aucune
convention
dans ces conditions la france et ses
partenaires engagés dans des missions de
lutte contre le terrorisme à savoir les
états participant à la task force
takouba ont pris la décision de retirer
leur présence militaire au mali
ce retrait
se traduira par la fermeture des
emprises de gossip de ménaka et de gao
il sera effectuée de manière ordonnée
avec les forces armées maliennes et avec
la mission des nations unies au mali ces
annonces ont suscité des commentaires
chez les candidats à la présidentielle
et responsables politiques certains
souhaitent que la présence militaire
française persiste en afrique pour
lutter contre le djihadisme on écoute
leurs réactions
je souhaite que la france reste au sahel
que nos militaires puissent continuer
cette lutte contre l'islamisme le
djihadisme au sahel en revanche je pense
que la façon dont la france est traitée
par la junte malienne n'est pas digne et
qu'on ne peut pas payer le prix du sang
pour un pays qui ne veut pas de vous ces
décisions de réorganisation est une
bonne décision xi s'est réorganisée mais
il ne faut pas partir comme l'ont fait
les américains en afghanistan il ne faut
pas abandonner ce terrain sur lequel la
france défend des valeurs universelles
il faut rester au sahel si on abandonne
ce terrain alors nos soldats seront sans
doute mort pour rien et ça je ne
l'accepterai pas les combattants de
l'opération barkan disparu au sahel ont
défendu nos valeurs nos libertés et la
possibilité pour les maliens de vivre
dehors de la soumission au djihadisme
c'était une opération très utile il faut
que les français restent sous une autre
forme dans la bande sahélienne même si
avec le mali c'est devenu plus compliqué
il va falloir continuer à maintenir une
présence parce qu'elle est demandée et
qu'elle est souhaitable pour notre
sécurité collective la france doit se
retirer de manière concertée du mali
voire du sahel le faire en concertation
avec ces pays elle doit surtout changer
de politique le monde a changé l'afrique
à changer la france n'a pas changé c'est
encore la françafrique la solution ne
sera pas militaire elle sera celle de la
coopération et du développement en tout
cas le mali est dans une mauvaise passe
sécuritaire la violence est toujours
présente
le pays est en proie à des combats
durent groupe jihadiste al qaïda au
maghreb islamique aqmi en deçà résine la
katiba massina par exemple dans le
centre et au nord l'onu a aussi pointé
des exactions commises par les forces de
défense et de sécurité maliennes
toutefois emmanuel macron a récusé
complètement ce sont ses termes l'idée
d'un échec français au mali vantant les
succès remportés par l'opération barkan
il a assuré que l'état malien se serait
effondré si la france n'était pas
intervenu en 2013 je rappelle que
c'était à la suite de l'appel au secours
de dioncounda traoré ancien président du
pays mais depuis la stabilisation n'est
toujours pas au rendez vous alors au
mali comment réagissent les populations
en retrait de barkan et takouba quel
bilan pour cette opération on voit cela
avec georges coulibaly journaliste
indépendant adana qu ici à bamako la non
ce n'est pas une surprise tant les
relations entre le mali et la france se
sont détériorées ces derniers mois ici
la force barkan fait l'objet des régions
auprès d'une grande majorité de la
population
les maliens que nous avons rencontrés
ont pour la plupart apprécié cette
décision du retrait de barkan a dû mali
écoutant quelques réactions il attend au
malin de trouver une nouvelle stratégie
pour les médias cette crise sécuritaire
nous souffrons il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui ont été tuées dans le nord
du pays à cause des attaques terroristes
nous voulons un mali apaisé nous prions
dieu et nous cherchons et nous avons
besoin de tous les moyens qui peuvent
aider le mali si le bonheur du mallié
dans le départ de barkan dans ce cas il
n'y a pas de problème mais si notre
bonheur n'est pas dans cette direction
nous continuerons à rechercher ce
bonheur moi je pense que quelque part
car parfois les pacanes reste ça démarre
sur le même souci ça des matériels un
problème parce que l'intégrité par
extrusion la force barca n'est pas la
seule remise en question il y a
également la force takouba qui fait
l'objet de critiques
les alliés de paris au sein de ta coups
bas mais aussi le canada vont quitter
le mali selon emmanuel macron les
militaires aux européens présents au
mali selon les déployer au niger et pour
en parler nous sommes avec vous m
rouillé si ses membres du conseil
national de transition pour soir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
devant viens de l'entendre à la force
française barque année l'opération
européenne takouba qui compte 40 % de
soldats français sont durement critiqué
un par la population à bamako c'est donc
on imagine pour eux un jour de fête
cette annonce de retrait
non je pense qu'il n'est pas vraiment un
jour de fête je dirais mieux donc que
c'est triste que la france sorte par la
petite porte après neuf ans d'engagement
je rappelle quand même qu'il ya cinq ans
nos soldats français qui sont tombés
dans celle et 52 sur le sol malien donc
effectivement partir comme ça si ça
reste un bilan mitigé pour les
populations maliennes où on ne se
réjouit jamais de ce genre de départ je
rappelle quand même que entre la france
et le mali là des lieux historiques ne
22 présences et aujourd'hui on voit
qu'avec
d'autres partenaires on avait à obtenir
des résultats s'il n'est pas être ingrat
à l'endroit de la france n'est pas le
mali qui a demandé le départ de des
forces barkani combat mais c'est l'état
français qui a su dans sa souveraineté a
fait rentrer ses soldats au parquet
sortir par la petite porte effectivement
c'était d'ailleurs y compris dans l'est
et dans les médias français aujourd'hui
le commentaire qui était assez
prédominant pourtant emmanuel macron
réfute l'idée d'un échec
il dit emmanuel macron l'état malien se
serait effondré sans notre intervention
à ce que vous partagez ce diagnostic
on peut si on remonte à 2012 2013
effectivement son arrivée des forces
françaises à l'époque il aurait eu
beaucoup de je pense que le mali aurait
beaucoup plus de soucis et
malheureusement malgré neuf ans de
présence je rappelle aussi qu'en 2013 on
avait
il n'y a qu'à voir la moitié du
territoire qui est occupé nous on dit
c'est 80 %
malgré serval de tags aux bras et barca
est donc un an de mieux pour se pose des
questions aujourd'hui grâce à dieu les
forces maliennes prennent du poil de la
bête sur le terrain il ya des résultats
qui sont tenus sur le thème est oui si
mark and parts ça donne un tu peux aussi
des réseaux pour le ministre malien
qu'avait il ya deux mois qu'avait
dénoncé un abandon après avoir donc
l'état malien a eu la bonne idée de
multiples et ses partenaires sinon je
pense que vous n'aurez subi le même cas
que l'afghanistan après le départ des
antilles donc c'était tout à fait
naturel pour nous d'anticiper ce n'est
pas parce qu'on savait que ça allait
arriver
l'ancien président françois hollande 1
qui a lancé cette opération
en 2013 dit aujourd'hui
que il aurait fait la même chose mais
aurait décidé d' un retrait plus précoce
est ce que c'est votre avis aussi et
macro aurait dû partir avant
non justement moi je pense qu on aurait
pu encore même chemise on parle bonne
intelligence et surtout dans le respect
de tous les pays engagés notamment de
mal et qui subit équipe et quand même le
prix lui aux tribus de cette crise et
cette crise n'est que de les
conséquences de l'engagement français en
libye ne cessera pas de le rappeler nous
n'oublions pas si vide au club ouali né
king victime collatérale de la guerre
engagée par les places sarkozy à
l'époque présente la république
française donc aujourd'hui une heure
française ap ap un lourd tribut mais un
homme tombé sur un sol étranger c'est
toujours un bilan très lourd mais il
faut qu'il reconnaisse aussi sa part de
responsabilité dans ce qui s'est passé
dans celle est qui n'est pas une insulte
à la mémoire des soldats français que de
le dire
pour vous justement sa part de
responsabilité elle se situe au
elle se situe à beaucoup au niveau de la
france avait quand même leadership
notamment sur en nous menons c'est ses
voisins européens et ses partenaires
européens et nord américains comme le
canada donc un moment donné partir comme
ça moi je dirais même que c'est de
parler contrairement à monsieur hollande
c'est un petit peu précipité on aurait
pu quand même entre guillemets lâcher la
main du mal y est présente tout seul
mais on savait que depuis trois quatre
mois la situation
allait crescendo et que l'on donne à
l'arrivée un au point du non retour
c'est dommage c'est dommage pour la
france c'est dommage pour le mali parce
que la qia est ce que le mali va pouvoir
tenir ses les mariés ne tient pas
économiquement n'oublions pas que les
mariés sa sanction donc c'est peut-être
des fils des jeunes qui vont aller
grossir les rangs des jihadistes tête
des jeunes qui sont les candidats à
l'immigration qui vont inonder bientôt
les les côtes européennes on va et c'est
ce qu'on disait le mali et éthiques si
le mali dont c'est aussi l'hymne
européen qui devrait s'inquiéter
davantage alors lors de cette conférence
de presse ce matin emmanuel macron a
évoqué également et fustigé un
d'ailleurs le recours du gouvernement de
transition à la société wagner je vous
propose de l'écouter
le phénomène que nous voyons au mali
c'est la présence des mercenaires la
société privée wagner la junte qui est
au pouvoir au mali après deux coups
d'état considère que ce sont les
meilleurs partenaires qu'ils peuvent
trouver pour protéger leur propre
pouvoir pas pour lutter contre le
terrorisme fois que j'ai dit ça je veux
ici le distinguer d'un lien avec l'état
russe la russie elle même en tant
qu'etat a déclaré publiquement qu'elle
n'était pas derrière cette présence il
n'y a pas de texte qui a été pris la
transition malienne n'a pas pris de de
traité permettant ce déploiement
militaire avec un état souverain comme
c'est le cas d'ailleurs avec nous autres
quand nous avons à nous déployer donc ce
n'est pas une relation d'état souverain
état souverain ne faut pas confondre
oublier ce qui se passe là avec d'autres
sujets géopolitique qui ne occupe et
dans lesquels la russie est un acteur en
tant qu'etat souverain assumer un acteur
militaire et diplomatique président
français qui fait clairement
la différence qu'ils disent aussi
clairement wagner et l'état russe mais
il sous-entend voilà que certains états
et notamment le mali la junte ne font
finalement appel à cette société russe
privé quelle est votre réponse
alors c'est qui est clair et il ya à peu
près deux mois le ministre des affaires
étrangères du mali à new york a
rencontré à moscou son homologue lavrov
donc dire que la russie n'est pas engagé
nous avons des instructeurs militaires
russes sur le sol malien est aujourd'hui
avec la russie il ya des résultats qui
sont tenus tout comme avec la france et
d'ici partie du territoire mais pas on
dissocie l'état russe effectivement et
cette société privée on sait ce que fait
d'ailleurs le président voilà il faut
dissocier mais il peut pas le nier aussi
que des instructeurs de l'armée russe
sont là officiellement donc d'établir un
partenariat d'état à état et dire que le
mal est fait appel aux mercenaires mais
ça commence mal avec la diro mallié je
rappelle qu en libye on a fait appel au
national je rappelle que en irak blake
auteur ait son mot à dire je rappelle
qu'on tirait des mercenaires aussi on
userait pour les puissances occidentales
donc ordonné qu'on a pas toujours sur le
plus fort taux dix ans d'épisodes encore
vingt neuf ans de présence et on savait
que ces débats allaient arriver tôt tu
as donc encore une fois il faut saluer
la clairvoyance du président assis les
guetta qui a anticipé le départ de
barkan et des troubles merci beaucoup
barbouillé si c'est d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france
ericsson aurait financé le terrorisme
c'est ce qu'a révélé à la presse
suédoise ce mardi le pdg de
l'équipementier télécoms après une
enquête interne des employés du groupe
basé en irak ont versé des pots de vin
des intermédiaires pour pouvoir circuler
sur certains axes contrôlés par des
ch'tis à exxon ne l'affirment pas
formellement cet argent a probablement
fini dans l'escarcelle du groupe
loyaliste
une affaire qui n'est pas sans rappeler
les agissements du groupe français
lafarge en syrie des explications de
guillaume à rossi pour une fois c'est le
coupable lui même qui enquêtent trouve
et avoue ses méfaits c'est assez rare
pour être souligné alors ericsson aurait
certainement préféré taire toute la
sphère et c'est surtout sous la pression
des médias suédois qu'ils ont enquêté de
leur côté que le patron du groupe est
passé aux aveux ce march en résumé
l'équipementier télécoms a lancé une
enquête interne il ya deux ans sur la
conduite de ses activités entre 2011 et
2010 9 en irak ericsson dispose d'un
bureau à bagdad et a par exemple
récemment étendu ses partenariats pour
moderniser le réseau sans fil du pays et
certains salariés ou fournisseurs du
groupe ont visiblement pris quelques
libertés avec la loi l'enquète a permis
d'identifier des preuves de mauvaise
conduite liés à la corruption a constaté
des violations des contrôles financiers
internes d'ericsson des conflits
d'intérêts le non respect des lois
fiscales et une obstruction à lenquête
et ça c'est le moins grave parce que
souvenez vous entre 2014 et 2016
principalement une partie du territoire
irakien se trouve sous la coupe de dash
et à ce moment là le seul choix qui
reste à de nombreuses entreprises
étrangères est le suivant quitter le
pays et abandonné leur activité ou
s'arranger avec l'organisation état
islamique et les employés d'ericsson en
irak semble avoir penché pour la seconde
option l'équipe d' enquête a également
identifié des paiements à des
intermédiaires et l'utilisation
d'itinéraires de transports alternatifs
pour contourner les douanes irakienne à
une époque où des organisations
terroristes dont des shs contrôler
certains itinéraires de transport des
schémas de paiement et des transactions
en espèces constituant potentiellement
un risque de blanchiment d'argent ont
également été identifiés alors évêque on
déclare ne pas être encore parvenus à
déterminer où cet argent a finalement
fini sa course très probablement pour
partie dans les coffres de
l'organisation état islamique ainsi que
le voulaient les us et coutumes de
l'époque c'est notamment ce qu'il s'est
passé avec lafarge dans le pays voisin
le cimentier est en effet soupçonné
d'avoir versé 13 millions d'euros à des
groupes terroristes en syrie entre 2013
et 2014 pour y maintenir ses activités
d'ailleurs le montant des bakchichs
versé par ericsson aux intermédiaires
irakien n'a pas été communiquée par le
groupe suédois on ne sait donc pas s'il
s'agit de milliers ou de millions
d'euros cela dit quelle que soit la
somme la réputation de l'équipement tir
n'a pris un coup le titre du suédois a
chuté de plus de 14% en 24 heures à la
suite des révélations de son pdg ce qui
a fait s'envoler du même coup plusieurs
milliards d'euros de capitalisation et
oui cette fois ci la faute avouée n'a
pas du tout été pardonné
sur le front de l'emploi en france à
présent aller relocalisation d'activités
industrielles ont permis de créer ou de
conforter près de 100000 emplois depuis
septembre 2020 c'est ce qu'affirme
aujourd'hui le gouvernement 782 projets
ont été recensés sur le territoire ces
deux dernières années selon un décompte
effectué par bercy un rapport nuancé
puisque entre 2000 et 2020 en compte un
million d'emplois perdus dans
l'industrie
et justement réindustrialiser la france
pour réduire aussi sa dépendance de
l'extérieur une nécessité pour la
plupart des candidats à la
présidentielle d'eric zemmour 1 fabien
roussel en partant en passant par
valérie pécresse les pénuries de masques
et de respirateurs au plus fort de la
crise du coc vides ont laissé un mauvais
souvenir aujourd'hui l'heure est donc à
la red red une industrialisation mais
sans doute ont vraiment les moyens
comment réindustraliser un pays comme le
nôtre qui s'est vidée de ses usines au
fil des décennies on en parle tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
seller de l'édito échos
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques sapir la
réindustrialisation c'est pas facile à
10,1 semble être au coeur de la campagne
présidentielle
si on croit évidemment les programmes de
quasiment tous les candidats oui tout à
fait et d'ailleurs il faut bien dire que
emmanuel macron lui-même mouiller sa
chemise avec en particulier le programme
france 2030 qui annonce des objectifs
relativement ambitieux maintenant il
faut comprendre aussi que on ne pourra
juger et jauger de cette ré
industrialisation que si on comprend
qu'elles sont les mécanismes qui ont
poussé à la désindustrialisation
depuis maintenant une trentaine d'années
alors tout d'abord dans quelle mesure la
france et d'un dea industrialisés alors
il faut bien voir que c'est d'abord sur
le l'emploi qu'on le voit le plus on
voit que l'emploi industriel et en
particulier on le voit sur le graphique
qui s'affiche c'est dans les industries
d'équipements autrement dit les machines
dans les industries de transport par
exemple l'automobile l'aviation et c'est
que les pertes d'emplois ont été les
plus importantes par contre
effectivement pour l'industrie
agroalimentaire il ya une relative
stabilité de l'emploi mais dont tout ce
qui est je dirais la partie noble de
l'industrie il ya des pertes d'emploi
tout à fait considérable alors est ce
qu'on peut dire que la concurrence
internationale a eu un effet déterminant
sur ce phénomène oui certainement même
si ce n'est pas le seul effet il faut
pas tout mettre sur le dos de la
concurrence air nation mais là et on le
voit sur cette autre graphique on voit
très bien qu'à partir de 2003 bien sûr
nous continuons à exporter toujours plus
de machines puisque là ce sont
uniquement les importations et les
exportations industrielles mais nous
apportons beaucoup plus et se creusent
un déficit commercial spécifique à
l'industrie qui explique par ailleurs le
jeu dur et l'immensité abyssal du
déficit commercial français actuel alors
est ce que cette désindustrialisation
n'est pas un phénomène en définitive
générale dans tous les pays développés
c'est vrai il y ait une
désindustrialisation partout mais ne se
fait pas au même rythme et ça c'est
important regardez là on voit sur ce
graphique nous sommes tombés aujourd'hui
en france a grosso modo 12 ressent pour
le poids de l'industrie dans le pib des
pays comme l'espagne ou l'italie se
retrouve au-dessus de 15% l'allemagne
elle met au dessus de 22% alors bien sûr
l'allemagne était dans les années 1970 à
36% donc elle est passée de 36 à 22 mais
nous nous étions à peu près à 26% et
nous sommes passés à 12% donc de gérer
que proportionnellement la baisse en
france est vraiment beaucoup plus
importante et y compris plus importante
qu'en italie et en espagne la question
c'est quelles en sont les causes de ce
que le fait de ces fameux impôts de
production dont on parle tant pendant
cette campagne présidentielle il ya à
l'évidence un problème de coût et ce en
dépit des aides que l'état de nos
entreprises et en particulier aux
entreprises industrielles et le montant
de ses dettes est absolument pharaonique
120 milliards d'euros par an c'était le
chiffre en 2018 bon on va pas tenir
compte du chiffre de 2020 évidemment
avec le quoi qu'il en coûte il a
beaucoup monté mais en 2010 820
milliards d'euros 5 5% du pib' en aide
et là on voit bien il ya deux grandes
masses dans cette haine il ya d'abord le
cic le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi et l'autre
chose ce sont les exemptions d'impôts
que ce soit des exemptions qui sont
liées aux charges sociales ou que ce
soit des exemptions fiscales qui
représentent elles aussi 40 milliards
donc c'est tout à fait considérable et
par rapport à ça si on prend maintenant
le poids des impôts de production mais
on voit qu'il ne représente que grosso
modo 2 % du pib 2,15 pour cent en
réalité c'est à dire grosso modo 50
milliards 50 milliards c'est quand même
moins que les 70 milliardaire et si on
supprime les impôts de production ce que
veulent de très nombreux candidats de
valérie pécresse à eric zemmour eh bien
ça ferait
170 milliards dead pour les entreprises
je suis désolé ça coûte un pognon de
dingue et s'il y a des assistés en
france c'est plutôt les entreprises
alors que se passe-t-il alors ce qui se
passe et c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que il y a deux raisons
fondamentales
on voit là le choix de l'étranger le
seul choix de l'étranger il est évident
les entreprises françaises ont choisi de
délocaliser pour échapper à des impôts
et pourtant on a vu l'ampleur des aides
qu'elle recevait mais aussi à cause du
coût du travail et on voit que les
entreprises françaises qui se sont
internationalisées
elles ont pratiquement les deux tiers de
leurs emplois hors de france alors que
la proportion est évidemment nettement
plus faible en allemagne est beaucoup
plus faible en italie ou en espagne
alors donc que fait-on pour rien de se
réaliser alors c'est vrai que c'est une
question qui va être délicate et on voit
d'abord qu'il ya un problème évident de
taux de change
rappelez-vous le premier graffin le 2ème
graphique qui s'est affiché à l'écran on
voyait bien que cette espèce de déficit
commercial spécifique à l'industrie il
avait démarré en 2003 donc on voit bien
c'est une conséquence de l'euro est
aujourd'hui l'écart de taux de change
entre la france et l'allemagne est
devenue absolument insupportable de ce
point de vue là il faut quand même se
souvenir quand on avait la possibilité
justement de dévaluer le franc si oui si
on se remet à cette époque là et bien
qu'est ce qu'elle fait le général de
gaulle en 1958 où nous avions un
problème qui était à peu près du même
ordre il a déprécié le franc de 37% en
deux opérations une en juin 58 l'autre
en décembre 58 même chose en 1969 après
la crise de 68 qu'est ce que fait le
président pompidou et giscard d'estaing
qui est à l'époque son ministre des
finances eh bien il des prêts si le
franc de 11% mais dans le même temps
l'allemagne réévaluent le deutsch mark
autrement dit là encore ça fait un choc
de compétitivité 2 22% donc oui c'est un
véritable problème et puis derrière il
faudra bien que l'état à un moment donné
contrôler les grandes stratégies des
entreprises et leur dit il n'est pas
possible pour des raisons ne serait-ce
que stratégique que vous continuiez à
délocaliser au niveau il fait et c'est
ce qu'on voit justement se profiler dans
les programmes des candidats alors c'est
pas exactement ce que l'on voit il ya un
tabou en france il faut le savoir c'est
le tabou de loro personne ne veut
toucher alors où d'ailleurs c'est un
petit peu différent avec la situation de
2017 et tant qu'on ne touchera pas à
l'euro tant qu'on ne posera pas la
question de l'euro est bien en réalité
on ne pourra pas réindustrialiser de
manière réellement efficace et puis il
ya un deuxième problème
il faudrait que l'on recueille
reconstitue l'équivalent de ce qui était
autrefois le commissariat général au
plan à la ruine nous avons un haut
commissaire au plan mais ce haut
commissaire au plan françois bayrou il
fait d'ailleurs bien son travail mais
qu'est-ce qui fait comme travail effet
un pur travail de prospective non le
plomb devrait si on veut vraiment
réindustrialiser définir des voix de
réindustrialisation et surtout contrôler
la stratégie des entreprises en fait le
seul espoir qui nous reste c'est
justement le plan nucléaire qui a été
annoncé dans le cadre france 2030 par le
président emmanuel macron parce que on
peut espérer qu autour de ce
développement de l'industrie nucléaire
eh bien on est une cristallisation des
autres entreprises industrielles merci
beaucoup jacques prost et mises en garde
et à la semaine prochaine avec olivier
nokere en flac et puis à dans deux
semaines avec moi merci en c'est à vous
et restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons la campagne
présidentielle à gauche comme à droite
tous bas ou trahison rythment le
quotidien des parties rien ne veut plus
notamment au sein du rassemblement
national l'art candidate lr valérie
pécresse elle elle n'a pas la sympathie
non plus de certains membres de sa
famille on parle dans quelques instants
[Musique]
mais
quels sont les sujets qui ont fait
l'actualité économique des derniers
jours a tout d'abord la dette américaine
moi je suis pas d'accord pour crier au
loup sur la dette publique tout
simplement parce que quand la dette
publique arrive à échéance l'état peut
toujours et emprunter la question étant
de savoir quel taux la dette c'est
d'impôts futurs c'est un moment où vous
apportera la noc quoi qu'il arrive donc
on peut pas dire on s'en fout toutes les
banques centrales et c'est un de juguler
l'inflation pendant que christine
lagarde qui est plutôt optimiste et je
dis souvent que j'aimerai pas être un
banquier central en ce moment pour une
raison simple c'est que vous disposez
pas en tant que banque centrale des
instruments qui sont nécessaires à
juguler l'inflation on a aujourd'hui
c'est du discours c'est de la com
attendez que le marché est un peu secoué
et vous verrez les banquiers centraux
revenir ventre à terre en disant ah
maintenant on est désolé on revêt ce les
taux
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
vous avez bouleversé un peu les codes la
de la pâtisserie moi je sentais que
j'avais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de créativité en moi
et qu'il allait être compliqué
d'attendre mon tour j'ai re questionner
en fait la pâtisserie quand on est chef
pâtissier ont nourri vous fait plaisir
là par la gourmandise par la beauté mais
on nourrit aussi donc pour moi le verbe
nourrir n'était pas assez bien respecté
la pâtisserie c'est le dessert que le
des soeurs
c'est à la fin à la carte de la légèreté
est absolument à maîtriser puisqu'on
veut du coup un dessert qu'ils soient
gourmand mais aussi très léger qui
viennent ponctuer un très bon dîner
tabac serait pour moi c'est beau c'est
bon et cela doit être également fin
parce que l'idée est le pari que je fais
c'est de se faire plaisir en se faisant
du bien
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas
l'oubli parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il y a trente ans l'union soviétique
s'est effondré comment avez vous perçu
ces événements à l'époque j'étais parmi
les partisans de la démocratie la
rédaction du journal russia se trouvait
à la maison blanche nous avons passé
deux nuits inoubliables à la rédaction à
la maison blanche on était au centre de
presse du ministère des affaires
étrangères lors de la célèbre conférence
de presse du comité d'état pour l'état
d'urgence j'ai bien sûr changé plusieurs
fois d'opinion sur ces événements comme
tout le monde s'en doute mais à ce
moment là il y avait bien sûr une sorte
d'euphorie démocratique s'enthousiasme
il n'est probablement si seulement
j'avais pu imaginer à l'époque en août
91 à quoi aboutir et ces événements avec
ce nom se terminerait cet enthousiasme
joyeux dans la lutte contre le monopole
du parti communiste et la censure en
apprenant coppens mais personne ne
pensait que cela aboutirait à
l'effondrement d'un grand pays pour moi
je suis responsable
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire les chroniques de campagne en
est à moins de deux mois du premier tour
de la présidentielle et à gauche comme à
droite les défections les combats ou les
trahisons rythment le quotidien des
parties rien ne va plus au sein du
rassemblement national marine le pen
trahi par son camp la candidate heller
lé ipcress n'est pas en reste non plus
présidentiel 2022 la campagne des
traîtres on attend vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme d'ayrté france
[Musique]
donc à deux mois de cette présidentielle
la candidate du rassemblement national
marine le pen a présenté son programme
destiné à la gestion de la retraite la
retraite le point d'orgue de cette
campagne des différents candidats en
lice pour la présidentielle faut-il
avancer ou reculer l'âge du départ zoom
sur les propositions des candidats avec
yamina benguigui
une réforme des retraites le ton est
donné par marine le pen lors de sa
conférence ce jeudi une réforme car
selon la candidate du rassemblement
national la gestion de la retraite doit
changer marine le pen promettent un
départ à la retraite à 60 ans avec 40
annuités pour les français qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 17 et 20 ans
avec un but bien précis celui d'inciter
à l'entrée sur le marché du travail le
plus tôt possible toute personne entrée
dans la vie professionnelle entre 17 et
20 ans sans condition particulière
pourra bénéficier d'un taux plein dès 60
ans avec 40 annuités soit un gain
considérable par rapport à la situation
actuelle de plus de deux années de
travail plus l'âge d'entrée dans
l'emploi sera bas plus le nombre de
trimestres nécessaires pour bénéficier
du taux plein sera lui aussi faible la
retraite elle revient dans tous les
discours de campagne et chaque candidat
a son idée sur la question alors que
l'âge légal de départ pour les salariés
nés après 1955 et de 62 ans ils sont
plusieurs à vouloir changer la donne à
commencer par le chef de l'état lui pas
encore candidat qui compte augmenter
l'âge de départ à la retraite comme la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse eric zemmour ce dernier
d'ailleurs projette de porter l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 64 ans en
proposant toutefois des ajustements pour
les personnes qui ont commencé plus tôt
pour pérenniser le système protecteur
des retraites par répartition il faudra
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
cette mesure sera modulé pour les
français qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt et ceux qui ont des métiers
difficiles un âge que valérie pécresse
souhaitait tirer jusqu'à 65 ans
progressivement d'ici 2030 la présidente
de la région ile de france dit vouloir
revaloriser le minimum contributif à
hauteur du smic net aujourd'hui fixé à
1000 230 euros pour le président de la
république
l'objectif est une retraite simplifié
emmanuel macron souhaite mettre fin aux
42 régimes spéciaux que compte la france
pour en garder que trois je pense qu'il
faut aller vers un système simplifié
grosso modo trois grands régimes plus à
gauche anne hidalgo souhaite maintenir
le départ à la retraite à 62 ans tout en
projetant de revaloriser les petites
retraites christiane taubira veut fixer
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 60 ans
en accordant une attention particulière
aux critères de pénibilité la retraite
n'est pas une question comptable c'est
une question de justice nous devrons
réformer pour les carrières longues pour
les métiers pénibles pour les plus
vulnérables de notre pays se son temps
c'est aussi l'âge de départ à la
retraite souhaité par le leader de la
france est soumise jean luc mélenchon le
candidat europe ecologie les verts
yannick jadot lui se positionne en
faveur d'un modèle de répartition qui
prend en compte la durée et la
pénibilité de la profession nous
permettront au contraire à toutes celles
et ceux qui ont exercé des métiers
pénibles de partir plus tôt à la
retraite de leur côté fabien roussel
nathalie arthaud candidate de la lutte
ouvrière et philippe poutou du nouveau
parti anticapitaliste sont tous d'accord
sur un départ à la retraite à 60 ans
voire plus tôt pour les métiers les plus
pénibles selon le lit lors du nouveau
parti anticapitaliste mais le parti du
rassemblement national qui continue de
se vider alors que le premier tour
approche à grands pas nicolas bay
officialise son aliment eric zemmour
l'ancien cadre du rassemblement national
explique ses raisons dans un entretien
au figaro eurodéputé a été suspendu la
veille par son ancien parti qu'il accuse
d'espionnage politique
j'ai décidé de m'engager pleinement aux
côtés d'eric zemmour dans la campagne
présidentielle
car je crois profondément dans sa
candidature son projet et sa stratégie
marine le pen fait une confusion entre
extrémisme et radicalité quand notre
pays est au bord du gouffre les mesures
à mettre en oeuvre sont forcément
radical et alors que la campagne
s'accélère les petites trahisons entre
amis battent leur plein marine le pen
n'est pas la seule à en faire les frais
valérie pécresse également eu son lot de
défections parmi ses rangs alors la
présidentielle 2022 et elle dominée par
les coups bas c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler en direct un
gilles casanova spécialiste en
communication également en direct eric
revel éditorialistes rt france bonsoir à
tous les deux sur ce plateau à boulogne
et non pas eric mathais directeur pierre
frais des guillemets mais elle est de
dreux bonsoir pierre frédéric biguier
jouer mendes secrétaire également de la
section du parti socialiste de bayonne
s'est également avocat merci à tous les
deux d'être là alors on viens de
l'entendre nicolas bay l'eurodéputé est
reine qui sera lié un finalement eric
zemmour on peut parler valley creveld
une nouvelle trahison pour marine le pen
oui évidemment on veut on peut parler de
trahison veux parler de transfuges bon
c'est pas d'une grande nouveauté en fait
un don les campagnes électorales on
assiste souvent régulièrement à des
transfuges ce qui passe d'un camp à un
autre bon vous appelez ça les trahisons
moi j'appelle ça des transfuges bon il
faut évidemment mettre en phase les
promesses que l'on fait à ceux qui
quittent à partie pour aller vers un
autre parti mais vous remarqué que quand
nicolas bay qui tu leur as hautmont
nationale pour aller chez eric zemmour
bon il ya l'épaisseur d'une feuille de
cigarette quand même entre les idées
globalement que portent ces parties même
si nicolas bay dans l'intérim du figaro
que vous rappeliez met face à face comme
si elle s'opposait les notions
d'extrémisme et de radicalité mais à mon
sens il ya plus grave dans la politique
française ya les transfuges des gens qui
parlent parfois pour un plat de
lentilles un peu plus croustillants et
puis il ya les trahisons des convictions
et pour moi c'est beaucoup plus
important les trahisons en matière de
conviction et là on a assisté ces
dernières années à des choses absolument
incroyable et je vous expliquerai
stéphanie pourquoi mon avis c'est plus
grave de trahir ses convictions que de
passer d'un parti à un autre en espérant
que le soleil brille un peu plus vous
souvenez peut-être nicolas sark j avais
fait de l'ouverture
un marqueur de son quinquennat et
notamment où il avait accueilli 7 8 9
transfuge du parti socialiste vous
souvenez peut-être de noms comme ceux de
bernard kouchner qui était socialiste
avec est devenu ministre des affaires
étrangères de nicolas sarkozy président
de droite vous souvenez sans doute
d'eric besson qui lui avait été
secrétaire dé l'économie au parti
socialiste puis qui quelques années plus
tard est devenu secrétaire général
adjoint de l'ump voyez là on trahit
complètement ses convictions parce du
parti socialiste à gauche à l'ump à
droite et puis il ya un autre cas
illustre inconnu qu'est jean pierre
jouyet jean pierre jouyet qui a été
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes de françois fillon et
françois
hollande qui était socialiste et qui une
fois qu'il a terminé son tour de piste
chez l'ump de l'époque est redevenu
secrétaire général de l'elysée lorsque
françois hollande lui même a été élu
président de la république on va partout
c'est très long et les crevettes parce
qu'on a je pense qu'on va faire on va
faire quatre heures là si on revient
mission des cas dits oui elle est bien
plus simplement vous dire que ces
trahisons convictions sont plus grave
parce que ça répond la petite musique
finalement la politique ce n'est pas des
convictions ce sont des places et les
rssi des français se détournent de la
chose politique
il faudrait regarder danser grand
nouveau de perdre de conviction si
l'origine de l'abstention si l'origine
de la défiance que les français ont
envers la politique ne vient pas de ce
type de phénomène grâce à un ajustement
mais mais mais mais mais mais trahir ses
convictions trahir son essence politique
ça me semble beaucoup plus grave restons
en tout cas sur cette campagne de 2022
et on va évidemment s'interroger parce
que c'est le pendant sur la raison de la
défiance et de l'abstention il n'empêche
marine le pen subi ces derniers temps
des départs successifs un gilbert
collard jérôme rivière encore stéphane
ravier sans doute peut-être l'une des
plus cruelles pour elle marion maréchal
le pen marion maréchal je crois qu'elle
enlevait le pen dans son nom
saint-janvier qui confie que la
cohérence la vision la stratégie la font
pencher pour eric zemmour gilles
casanova en essayant de répondre pas
trop longtemps parce qu'on est c'est
vrai qu'on ait quatre sur le plateau
s'interroge quand même sur la stratégie
notamment de marine le pen ce qu'elle
doit se remettre en cause des lic
rebelles par les porosités avec eric
zemmour mais enfin il ya peut être aussi
un changement de stratégie pour la
présidente du fn
le coeur du problème c'est le découplage
complet entre la masse de la population
et une toute petite élite politico
médiatique qui fait qui agit et qui
commet elle même à travers le système
médiatique le système politique et comme
elle ne parle que d'elle même elle ne
rencontre pas la population c'est ça le
problème la population elle est sur un
standard droite ou gauche
quand on pose des questions de fond aux
gens ça n'a pas changé c'est même un peu
plus à gauche qu'avant est ce qu'il faut
faire payer les riches il n'y a jamais
eu autant de gens qui ont répondu oui
que en ce moment et il ya d'autres
sujets des sujets nouveaux par exemple
grand remplacement 61% des français
craignent le grand remplacement autant
d'électeurs de mélenchon ou à peu près
que des lecteurs de valérie pécresse
donc vous voyez que dans la société
telle qu'elle est pour 90 % de la
société on est sur un référent droite
gauche avec des nouveaux problèmes mais
qui se joue dans ce référent devra de
gauche et puis dans la petite élite
politico médiatique on est dans un jeu à
trois et pas à 2 nous avons la
contestation nous avons l'identité et
nous avons l'argent l'identité est bien
on a des reclassements sur qui est le
meilleur pour être le représentant du
groupe identitaire dans ce triangle du
sommet et donc c'est les échanges entre
la famille le pen et puis un nouveau
venu qui a un discours quand même qu'ils
répondent un peu plus aux attentes des
gens et qui est
un peu moins marquée par l'histoire le
pen nous avons la contestation avec jean
luc mélenchon qui est le plus
représentatif de cette contestation est
donc il attire les gens qui ne veulent
pas filer vers l'argent ségolène royal
par exemple nous avons l'argent avec au
coeur macron et puis tous ceux qui
approchent venant de droite ou de gauche
parce que l'attrait de l'argent est
toujours très fort pierre frédéric
billet on parlera évidemment du cac dlr
parce que valérie pécresse on le disait
a aussi ses petits soucis en ce moment
mais quelle est votre lecture de ces
petites trahisons alors que eric revel
appellera ça autrement mais enfin quand
même 1 rn1 elle l'a vécu comme tel
marine le pen elle s'en est pas caché
c'est la dédiabolisation qui a pas
forcément payé il fallait rester sur une
ligne dure la trahison politique c'est
vieux comme la politique c'est à dire
que quand on reprend dans l'histoire
monsieur revel en parler c'est vieux
comme la politique
maintenant il ya quelques nouveautés
alors on sent bien qu'il ya des
trahisons des ralliements pour
différentes raisons vous avez leur
assemblée nationale les gens partent
parce qu'ils préparent l'après
présidentielle ça on le sent bien ils
veulent recomposer la droite s'est
retiré le projet de monsieur émouvant
ensuite il ya des trahisons à gauche
aussi on voit que madame royal alors ne
soutient pas mais en tout cas dit que le
vote utile c'est effectivement monsieur
mélenchon ce qui est assez drôle
d'ailleurs parce que monsieur mélenchon
a quitté le parti socialiste en 2008
parce que sa motion était arrivée celle
derrière celle madame royal donc c'est
assez drôle de voir qu'il ya des
retournements comme ça le parti
communiste français s'est fait blouser
par monsieur mélenchon avec qui il avait
fait les filles et ses accès donc c'est
vieux comme le monde alors chez nous
chez les verts il ya quelques trahisons
aussi quoique ça se tient plutôt pas
trop mal parce que quand on regarde donc
chez monsieur jadot vous avez vu un jet
d'eau maintenant être tout seul dans son
bateau madame rousseau est rentrée chez
elle sur rigole et ses accès donc ça
c'est une vérité maintenant et je veux
dire que chez vous alors il ya peu chez
nous semble-t-il quand même on a aussi à
voir lui dit les centristes avec nous
les a rassemblés monsieur woerth est
parti guillaume pelletier partie mais
guillaume pelletier quelque part il est
revenu à ses premiers amours voilà il
est revenu à l'extrême droite donc une
certaine logique eric woerth c'est un
cas un peu pas un peu particulier parce
que monsieur eric woerth quand même
un peu se moquer du monde c'est à dire
que quand il dit que monsieur macro n'a
pas cramé la caisse c'est une vaste
fumisterie une vaste plaisanterie
d'ailleurs monsieur macron aussi un
grand de la trahison avec monsieur
hollande quand même vous voyez
l'histoire se répète l'échelle et l'air
on est plutôt et cohérent l'équipe est
là et derrière valérie pécresse on se
tient quelques ralliements à droite à
gauche mais globalement par rapport à ce
qu'on voit on n'est pas si malheureux
que ça je m'adresse on parlait à gauche
voilà vous avez aussi vos petits tracas
ségolène royal effectivement petite
petite revanche peut-être voilà qui
aurait dû logiquement soutenir anne
hidalgo vous vous comprenez détritus de
de l'ancienne candidate à la
présidentielle le vote utile mélenchon
vous vous partagez
françois mitterrand disait que sur le
chemin de la trahison il n'y a que le
fleuve de la route à traverser ségolène
royal en fait je le regrette quand même
anne hidalgo la démonstration c'est vrai
que voilà ségolène royal je crois à
quitter le camp des socialistes il ya
bien longtemps enfin il ya bien
longtemps c'était en 2017 où il avait
appelé à voter pour emmanuel macron donc
si vous voulez je pense que ségolène
royal n'est plus socialiste elle fait
ses petits arrangements cette petite
tambouille politique un petit peu
j'en suis totalement conscient il faut
poser la question à ségolène royal qu'il
est voilà qui n'est plus socialiste moi
en tant que militant bien sûr que ça me
choque c'est est la candidate du parti
socialiste qui arrivait au second tour
qui a fait sa carrière grâce au parti
socialiste il faut quand même le dire et
je trouve toujours regrettable bien
voilà de trahir vu que c'est le terme
que j'utiliserai ses convictions au non
je ne sais peut-être quelques vengeance
ou quelques arrangements personnels et
pierre ferring et pour revenir voilà
sur cette droite est ce que le problème
aujourd'hui n'est pas cette porosité qui
est de plus en plus flagrante entre
voilà la droite conduit extrême et et la
droite dite républicaine
weir est plus qu à une traditionnelle
est effectivement alors ça ça pouvait
effectivement une des craintes après la
primaire en tout cas le congrès ait
l'air eric zemmour estimé qu'une partie
des militants l ère allait le rejoindre
notamment ceux qui avaient voté pour
eric ciotti ça n'a pas été le cas c'est
flagrant maintenant donc on voit bien
quand même que les vieux partis comme
les nôtres qui ont une histoire sont
ancrées sont assez fidèles à la famille
politique le parti socialiste kaka quand
même un ancrage territorial qui est
quand même assez puissant sur le
territoire français il ya une certaine
cohérence nous en plus il ya la figure
un peu gaullienne sur le parti on voit
bien quand même que ça tire la boutique
et puis il ya quand même des gens qui
sont de bon niveau vous avez bertrand à
michel barnier qui rassemble toute la
famille et effectivement je pense que
l'échec de monsieur zemmour là dessus ça
a été notamment le fait de ne pas
constater un départ massif même
anecdotique de dlr vers son parti eric
revel votre vision sur ce que vient de
dire à pierre frédéric billets c'est
vrai la famille gaulliste traditionnel
qui se soude il n'empêche pays pécresse
est en difficulté en ce moment après
cette séquence du zénith de paris elle
est désormais devancé par eric zemmour
dans plusieurs sondages
votre lecture justement ça suscite
parfois des dd trahison presque naturel
oui mais il ya une autre forme de
trahison monsieur le maire que dont on
ne parlait pas évidemment ça vous gêne
peut-être un peu c'est la trahison des
idéaux que portait le rpr des années 90
le rpr des années 90 il a été il mettait
sur la table des idées et ses idées eric
zemmour a expliqué à hato a raison mais
en tout cas une partie des électorats
fillonniste le suivi parce que cet
électorat estimé cette partie des
électorats estimé que ce que vous disiez
lorsque le rpr existait dans les années
90 avec des pots de ordre très fort
notamment sur l'immigration
l'ump puis les verts l'ont totalement
blum et donc il ya les transfuges il ya
les trahisons il ya les ralliements mais
il ya aussi des partis politiques qu'ils
renoncent à leurs idées et qui pour une
partie non négligeable de l'électorat
ont trahi leurs idées si vous regardez
les sondages il s'apercevrait que
valérie pécresse de cap que 54 % de
l'électorat fillonniste d'il ya cinq ans
emmanuel macron 20% et eric zemmour 18 à
19% 6% seulement pour marine le pen mais
ça veut dire qu'il ya une partie de vos
électeurs qui croyaient au rpr et aux
idées que portait le rpr en 80 dans les
années 90 et qui ne croient plus à aux
idées que porte aujourd'hui l'air donc à
transfuge ralliement mais il ya aussi
monsieur le maire trahissons dans les
idées que les parties portait dans votre
jeu mendes ça va pas sonner le glas
cette élection de de tous les partis
traditionnels on voit sa part chez les
mouche et m ont parlé de ségolène royal
qui fait un grand écart c'est la fin
vraiment des parties des gros partis
traditionnels c'est vrai qu'avec
l'élection d' emmanuel macron on peut
convenir qu'il a mis un coup de pied
dans la fourmilière et que ça soit la
droite ou la gauche ont eu du mal à s'en
remettre à se restructurer et
aujourd'hui en bien que c'est le cas en
tant que
républicain attaché aux partis
politiques qui pour moi structure la vie
politique je ne peux que regretter un
petit peu ça a été dit c'est une
tradition des idées notamment de la
droite on pourra dire que chacun balaye
devant sa porte mais sur la droite pour
un parti qui se dit républicain on vous
l'avait dit à une porosité tout à fait
regrettable entre la droite et l'extrême
droite pour une partie qui se dit
gaulliste on l'a vu au meeting de madame
pécresse sur la question du grand
remplacement on le voit avec eric ciotti
qui représente une ligne et il n'a pas
hésité à le dire sans cacher qu'il
serait prêt en cas de second tour entre
marine le pen
en second tour entre pardon en trombe
emmanuel macron eric zemmour a voté pour
eric zemmour donc on voit bien cette
porosité qui gêne en tout cas je pense
que si la gauche a des difficultés elle
est très claire sur ces sujets une
gauche républicaine qui s'assume et
social démocrate mais une gauche en
difficulté aussi sam mendes ça on peut
pas le contester une gauche en
difficulté et de manière plus générale
une question qui auxquelles nous devons
répondre c'est qu'est ce qu'être
socialiste au 21ème siècle aujourd'hui
et j'en conviens qu'on a du mal à
répondre à cette question bien qu anne
hidalgo propose un programme clairement
social démocrate mais bien après
l'élection c'est une question à laquelle
il faudra répondre ça je ne le conteste
pas pierre fatigué vous dites oui la
droite traditionnelle droite dans ses
bottes unis l'autre jour on avait un
invité philippe karsenty qui est
encartée au l est républicain soutien
d'eric zemmour ça vous choque ça se oui
vous vous trouvez une forme de logique
même non c'est pas ça je pense que on
pour répondre à monsieur mendes très
rapidement je compte valérie pécresse a
toujours été exemplaire sur la sur la
frontière entre l'extrême droite et et
et notre parti donc là dessus a pas de
débat avec sutil à sa parole est libre
ça c'est pas un sujet je reviens sur ce
qu'a dit monsieur revel bon il attaque
un petit peu monsieur revel a comme une
grande grande expérience d'apolitique
quand on reprend les programmes des
partis politiques des années 80 pour les
comparer pour les comparer aux fins de
comparaison aujourd'hui bon c'est un peu
tiré par les cheveux on pourrait
reprendre le programme pcf et de
monsieur mitterrand 2 81-11 irait mais
où sont les convictions et c'est donc
monsieur rebelles et six rebelles fait
un petit jeu de passe-passe as-tu bon
intellectuellement c'est pas tout à fait
honnête je pense monsieur revel ce n'est
pas de votre niveau en tout cas me
semble-t-il donc maintenant 1 6i se
tient aux honnêtes gens non monsieur
notation pourraient receler
90 on est tous les partis
et vous verriez que les l'évolution
programmatique ce qui est tout à fait
logique le fn années 80 était plutôt sur
le lean gregan le parti socialiste
années 80 était pro prolétariat ce qui
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui et puis
nous on a évolué aussi donc faire des
comparaisons là dessus je trouve que
c'est un petit peu si on reprend les
déclarations de gaston defferre ancien
maire de marseillan sa ministre sur
l'immigration ça choquerait tout le
monde aujourd'hui donc vous voyez bon je
pense qu'on peut faire d'archéologie
mais c'est un peu antidaté quoi le tir
et voilà gilles casanova avant justement
on parlait des des conséquences un petit
peu de ces petits arrangements entre
amis qui sont parfois un petit peu mal
perçue par par les électeurs justement
votre vision parce qu'on parle
énormément de cette droite aujourd'hui
qui se cherche un peu qui va peut-être
se réinventer après cette élection
justement la difficulté qu'il y a c'est
que le parti socialiste comme l air ne
sont pas dans le triangle que j'ai
évoquées contestation identité argent ne
sont pas placés dans ce triangle donc
vous avez une partie de dirigeants du ps
qui n'ont pas du tout comme ségolène
royal rejoint jean luc mélenchon mais
qui ont expliqué que la social
démocratie c'était macron c'est à dire
le ralliement au courant central au bloc
élitaire vous avez une partie avec
woerth qui fait la même chose chez
heller et puis vous avez une partie
hachée et l'air comme chez les
socialistes qui va vers la contestation
d'un côté ouvert l'identité de l'autre
c'est à dire que nous avons en absence
d'une cohésion entre la sphère politique
la sphère médiatique et la population un
discours médiatique complètement
extérieure à ce qui se passe avec des
petites discussions sur monsieur machin
va-t-il apporter des voix monsieur truc
va-t-il apporter des voix dont monsieur
machin puisque truc vont gagner de
l'argent voilà soyons clairs ils vont
apporter aucune voix à personne parce
que de toute façon vous n'avez plus 15 %
des français qu'ils font confiance à
quelque parti ou quelques personnalités
politiques que ce soit et c'est là le
problème majeur vous avez deux parties
qui ont un grand nombre d'élus locaux ps
et l air et ses deux parties sont
incapables de se placer dans le jeu
politique des élites et ils sont
incapables de répondre aux attentes de
la base sociale des uns et des autres
alors là il ya un double problème très
explosif justement vous avez raison
parce que ses électeurs il semble
parfois déstabilisés par ces revirements
d'ailleurs je vous propose d'écouter
marine le pen sur ce sujet après la
défection donc de nicolas mais il ne
pouvait plus rester à mes côtés à partir
du moment où les gens se tiennent mal où
ils sont déloyaux ça ne me dérange pas
qu'il parte mais pourquoi rester dans la
campagne le plus longtemps possible pour
saboter de l'intérieur la campagne et
pour finir par faire un cinéma et partir
des comportements comme ça pousse des
gens à arrêter de voter et même tonalité
dans ce message télégramme qui vient de
nous parvenir maxime avec tous ces
traîtres comment peut-on se fier aux
candidats comment peut-on avoir envie
d'aller voter et les crevel réfuté le
terme de traitement fin je mendes et si
ça le problème parce que vous ça vous
semble peut-être naturel normal on le
voyait avec eric revel qui commente la
politique depuis quelques années mais
les électeurs eux ça nourrit la défiance
ça nourrit l'abstention à la question
comment décrédibiliser davantage la
parole politique l'engagement politique
je pense que ce petit mercato politique
assez exécrable en est malheureusement
la démonstration j'ai 26 ans j'ai un
engagement politique depuis mes 15 ans
bien sûr je m'intéresse et je milite aux
côtés d'anne hidalgo mais pour ma
génération les amis avec lesquels je
discute c'est vrai que au delà de ces
petits comportements individuels pour
des postes et bien ça interroge sur la
halle la question de s'intéresser à la
chose publique à aller voter c'est vrai
que moi j'essaye de convaincre ici ou là
qu'il faut aller voter même si on
partage pas les mêmes convictions et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que ces
comportements blesse davantage
l'engagement et la parole publique et et
voilà je pense qu'il faut être clair sur
ses opinions
qu'on soit de droite ou de gauche ce qui
permettra je l'espère dans les années à
venir bien de donner un bout
supplémentaire à l'engagement et à la
parole
on vous dit quoi sur le terrain à dreux
les électeurs justement quand on voit
eric woerth qui a toujours critiqué menu
émettront qu'il ait rejoint soudainement
c'est vrai que ça fait pas forcément
bonne impression quand on voit le nombre
d'abstentionnistes alors c'est tout à
fait vrai faux souvenirs quand même
qu'aux législatives et en 2017 on a eu
50 % de participation donc c'était
historiquement bas on m'a fait une
réflexion ce matin qu'ils étaient très
intéressantes sur eric woerth on m'a dit
si j'étais bruno le maire je
m'inquiéterais pour mon poste oui
c'était tout à fait intéressant c est
frappée du bon sens oui les gens sont
pas encore dans la campagne électorale
ouais on sent bien il regarde ça de loin
ils sont pas encore est ce que justement
il n'y a pas ce genre de comportement de
n'éloigne pas les gens tout simplement
ça t'intéresse savait pas forcément
bouger beaucoup de voix on a besoin
c'est un peu brouillon ces espèces de
tambouille politique c'est assez
désagréable
les gens prennent de la distance moi je
sens bien je discute tous les skis
toujours avec les avec les drouet ma
très belle ville de dreux et les gens se
prennent un petit peu de distance il
faut dire aussi la vérité c'est que
beaucoup de gens attendent que emmanuel
macron descendre dans l'arène voilà ça
c'est un vrai sujet parce que
aujourd'hui on parle entre nous on débat
est une espèce de mystère autour d'eux à
quel moment il va se déclarer c'est ça
devient assez désagréable pour le débat
démocratique
il faut quand même le noter on a besoin
à la fois de débattre avec le président
sortant parce qu'il veut être candidate
on le sait et puis de faire le bilan et
de ce qu'ils proposent par la suite
parce que il faut avoir en tête quand
même la cour des comptes l'a démontré
sur la dette de la france les les enjeux
à partir de 2022 2023 vont être telle
qu'on doit avoir un débat long et
démocratique sur le fond qu'est ce qu'on
fait de notre dette la réforme du
système de santé la réforme du système
de sécurité sociale de l'état et cetera
et cetera et ça c'est pas en deux trois
semaines qu'on va le faire donc j'espère
que vite le débat vint s'installer qu'on
aura les vrais débats de fond notamment
sur les plateaux télé eric revel
justement cette embrouille politiques
sont pas de nature à freiner le vrai
débat de fond finalement il ya deux
choses qui ferait les bad boys à ce que
vient de dire monsieur le maire c'est à
dire le rapport de la cour des comptes
est très alarmiste sur niveau de la
dette est ce qu'on appelle la sincérité
de la trajectoire budgétaire pour 2027
vous faites un cadrage et vous dites en
2027 on sera dans les clous des critères
de maastricht est en fait la cour des
comptes dit bah il faut 9 à 10 milliards
d'euros d'économies supplémentaires
chaque année si on veut aller dans cette
trajectoire budgétaire ce qui paraît
absolument impossible mais la question
fondamentale c'est qu'avec le niveau de
dette que nous avons aujourd'hui les
2900 milliards d'euros de dette un
déficit public qui a explosé à commerce
extérieur qui est totalement en panne
qui accumule les déficits en fait on
peut se poser une question et les
électeurs vont se la posent et je pense
c'est qu'au delà de toutes les promesses
qui sont faites par tous les candidats
combien sont finançables avec l'état
actuel de la dette combien de milliards
d'euros promis sur les propositions de
candidats vont rester lettre morte parce
qu'elles ne sont pas finançable vu le
niveau de la dette en france quand vous
lisez le rapport de la cour des comptes
et bien tout ça se traduit dans un
indicateur à mon sens ce qui est
l'indicateur de l'abstention en 80
élection présidentielle vous avez 80% de
participation en 2017 vous avez 76 75 %
de participation de mémoire et dans le
dernier rolling d'harris interactive on
en l'air on en est à 66 % de
participation donc ça veut dire que en
fait au fur et à mesure des années les
français se déplacent de moins en moins
ils croient peut-être de moins en moins
ou promesses qu'on leur fait ils y ont
cru y croit de moins en moins et quand
vous avez le rapport produit par pierre
moscovici qu'est le premier président de
la cour des comptes ce matin qui dit bah
on a une dette qui est difficilement
soutenable ceux qui vous disent qu'ils
vont dépenser davantage pour vous rendre
plus heureux bah écoutez le mais écoutez
les mines et cronje pas forcément
de reparler de ses ventes ce problème de
cette campagne électorale avec vous et
eric revel et avec nos candidats qui
défileront sur ses plateaux merci à tous
les quatre monsieur casanova eric revel
pierre frais des billets et joe mendes
merci à vous et c'est la fin de cette
émission à l'actualité continue toute la
soirée en direct sur arte france
[Musique]
quels sont les sujets qui ont fait
l'actualité économique des derniers
jours tout d'abord la dette américaine
je suis pas d'accord pour crier au loup
sur la dette publique tout simplement
parce que quand la dette publique arrive
à échéance l'état peut toujours et
emprunter la question étant de savoir à
quel taux la dette c'est de la peau
futur c'est à un moment où vous
apportera